hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to be answering questions that
people have blessed on our Telus talks
business posts i've created a couple new
posts in a series called entrepreneur
tools where i'm highlighting the tools
that i use throughout my business and
it's been a lot of questions that have
come in so i thought i'd do a quick
video to answer some of them the first
one we did was on Evernote and this is a
great tool that helps you remember all
the information that you need to
remember across all your different
devices and I talked about how I use it
to create a paperless office and for
receipts how to return purchase my ipad
business notes I'll use it for my travel
you can go back and read the post if you
want but I want to get down to some of
the questions that came in so the first
one that was a question was from ethyl
here so hi Evan that's a great app but
what what if I what do i do if i don't
have a scansnap does it use another
scanner so a great way that i use
evernote that i talked about in the
video is I have a paperless office by
using a scanner called scansnap and from
there I can access all of my receipts
that the documents anything important
that is paper originally and have it
saved in my every note so i can quickly
search for it and find out whenever I
want ever scansnap is a specific scanner
that's created by fujitsu i think and it
basically integrates with evernote
seamlessly so it can do full text
recognition so if you're looking for a
receipt from the home depot or bestbuy
or whatever you bought you can just type
in home depot and it will find the
scanned receipt for you I if you don't
have this can snap I don't know if there
are other scanners that do it a lot of
people talk about this can snap a lot of
bloggers use them and so that's why I
picked it up and I've loved it ever
since but if you don't have the scansnap
you're looking for a different scanner I
just make sure that there's a
integration with Evernote so it's easy
I'm all about making things easy and
efficient and the creating processes so
scansnap really is the best way to do it
that I found but if you're looking for
another scanner I just try to make sure
they have that Evernote
integration but if you don't have a
scanner yet then check out scans have a
lot of different options I used the
mobile portable one so it's not that
expensive you can go up to really
expensive you know huge ones if you have
a ton of stuff but I think as a as an
entrepreneur the portable one should be
fine but up to you can check it out
different prices and see what works so
that was the first question and lots of
comments on these which is good Peter
wrote in this is quite powerful
particularly for me I'm an emerging
business person and have often found
challenges and managing my too many
papers particular when I travel this
will prove to be quite handy how do i
how do I have Evernote I'm inspired so
Peter all you have to do is go to
evernote com so you know whatever
software you're using or operating
system just go to evernote com and here
you can download so you just click get
evernote it's free and that'll create it
on your your computer and if you have
ipad or iphone you just have to go to
the web store or you should be able to
do it from the website as well and
install the app and again it's free to
get started you get a lot of space and
everything for free if you really need
to upgrade then you can and it's still
pretty cheap to upgrade but i definitely
recommend getting started on the Free
Package see if you're using it and see
if it's helping you do what you want to
do and then upgrade if you need to but
even that it's not that expensive so
just go to evernote com free and check
it out so hopefully that answers your
question there Peter on our YouTube
video so attached with the poster I
always create a video to kind of explain
what i'm doing is the first time filming
the ipad so it was a fun experience to
go through and hopefully kind of shows
you guys a little bit more about it we
had a question here from John let's go
find John so you know here it is so John
so thanks Evan always liked the tools
can you clarify the following what
skynyrd you use to scan in all the small
visa receipts and awkward sized ones
that don't feed into a regular scanner
easily so again it's called a scansnap
so for just type in skin snap
do a quick little Google search that
should pull it up so yeah it is fujitsu
scansnap fujitsu calm or whatever
country you're from you can find a local
one and you don't just go search and you
can find the different options to bias
can snap again there's different prices
different models just pick the one that
suits you best i'm using just the
portable one was not expensive and it
serves all of my needs so that was what
it's called scansnap and do you do
anything special to make the skin in PDF
searchable that is a major missing
feature my current digital file system
using Dropbox basically can only search
by file name and as a lot of unnecessary
work when scanning the receipts invoices
to names of files yeah that's a great
point so with scansnap you have to set
it up properly so first of all scans app
will just automatically save a file in
your computer you have to set it up so
that it syncs with evernote that's where
the real power comes in otherwise you
just have a PDF on your computer when
you can sync with every now it's just
one of the settings then in there you
can load up your evernote and you can
have access to all of the files that
come in another one of the options with
scansnap is to be able to make the files
full-text searchable which is what you
want so that means when you then go to
Evernote you can type in a word and
it'll pull up any receipt that you're
looking for and that's huge like you're
not searching through shoeboxes full of
receipts and trying to keep a filing
system of where everything is we're
trying to remember when you bought it or
where you bought it you can just do a
full text search so you just have to
turn that on and then all your future
ones will be automatically safe you also
have the option to to scan it in in
color or black and white so depending on
what you're scanning in the color takes
a little bit longer so I usually just do
black and white for business stuff
because usually that's all I need and
you have the option to double sided or
single sided so the payment what it is i
usually do single sided because again it
takes longer to do double-sided even if
the back page is blank and takes up a
little bit more space so i usually do
single sided unless unless the file is
double sided and then finally have an
option to do
how much how much quality do you need so
you can have really really high quality
or you can have low quality and kind of
everywhere in between I could play
around with it I'm nowhere near that the
high quality setting unless I'm scanning
in a picture or something that I want to
keep and it's important that's good
quality it was just documents receipts
tax you don't really need it to be super
high quality the higher the quality the
longer it also takes the scan so if
you're scanning a whole bunch of
receipts you know you don't want to
spend too long doing it so I found that
the be super helpful there's a lot of
different options you could play with so
definitely check out the settings sounds
like i'ma I should be a salesperson for
scansnap I have no affiliation with it
but it's a great product and it
integrates really well with with
Evernote and their tech team is actually
pretty good too if you have any problems
connected with them on one occasion it
was really helpful so hopefully that's a
that's useful for you John moving on the
next post that we did was about last
pass and last pass is a really cool tool
that allows you to remember all your
passwords and it helps you create random
secure passwords for new services that
you're signing up for online and it also
lets you automatically log in to all
your site so you don't have to ever
remember your passwords again so this is
a most recent tool that we did is also
an app that you can put on your iPad
that I talked about quickly where the
basic can browse to your app and if you
create an account through you know so
you create a new paypal account do you
create and whatever web service account
you can just go to your iPad install the
app and it will remember your password
to login to that site so that's really
awesome time-saving tool instead of
having to always remember what your
passwords are so we had a couple
questions again here is a video talk
about how I use it so you can definitely
check out the post if you want and let's
go down 320 Commons are just pretty good
let's go look for jihad so this one here
or you can have safari it will also
they're always remember you use your
password automatically across all the
hardware I just find it useful and don't
have to remember it though I do use data
vault so we can save all my sensitive
data so don't forget it so there is an
option in Safari I'm not super familiar
with it
tend not to use safari as I use chrome
and I like all the plugins and
extensions that come with chrome I
believe was so far you may be able to
log in and have remember it across
different different computers I don't
know if it works with iPads and iPhones
as well so something to check out so it
saves it in the history I'm not sure if
it'll do that or not so that that could
work the benefits of using lastpass
instead of that is one it'll create
passwords for you so here you have to
remember in Safari you still have to
create a password on your own with
LastPass it'll also automatically log
you in so it just saves a click right so
if you go into whatever page you're
logging into your paypal account or
Facebook account or whatever it is it'll
automatically log you in right away
instead of having you having to you know
click that extra button to go through
and it's also I find a lot more secure
so when you're browsing I have the
option if you look at this here this
this yellow thing is last past and I can
turn that on and I can turn it off and I
have to set my password to do that and I
can pick what sites I want it to
automatically log me into and which ones
i don't so every time I log into a site
it asked me if I want to remember this
password or not the reason that's more
important that's important is because if
anybody else ever uses your computer
then you know they would have complete
access if you just store it in Safari
they'd be able to go into any of your
files in n log in automatically turn of
your accounts where was last pass you
can safely say okay these are the ones
who want to automatically log into or
not so again last class is free so you
know given the option it just saves a
lot of time everything is a lot more
secure you can have everything across
all your devices so I would just do that
instead of using safari but gettin up to
you yeah i'm just showing what i'm using
and hopefully gives you some ideas what
to do and then one last question here
came from lewis I like it a lot however
I think that you being a chrome user you
must know that saves all your passwords
if you so want it ok sure it doesn't
create it but you can always create your
own password your own like your own
linking right yes he creates more secure
password but again if you forget your
LastPass password all your passwords are
there
despite all the above I agree it's easy
to have such software so thanks for
sharing so yeah similar to the Safari
question you could try to save it in
chrome again issues about getting across
all your devices and also creating the
password and how secure is that if you
forget your LastPass password then yes
you know that you have to remember that
one passwords you will get into all your
other passwords but just like anything
else they have a tool to remember if you
forget your password they have a lost
password tool so you can just enter in
your email and you can reset your
LastPass password as long as you still
have access to your email account I
guess that's where it could potentially
fall down but yeah it does help to
remember your last pass password but
otherwise there's always a way to reset
it so in case you do forget it you can
still get access to it so hopefully that
helps a lot of great questions come in
and about the tools we're going to be
creating more videos about tools over
the rest of the year and we'll see how
it goes it was a test project and it
seems to be getting some good feedback
so we really appreciate that so if you
guys have liked this video really
appreciate if you give it a thumbs up
but what's it's what makes me want to
create more of these videos for you guys
and if you have any questions about
tools that I'm using or any other
questions about your business feel free
to leave it in the comment section below
I always check those out and read them
and you know appreciate seeing those
come in and love being able to be a
resource for you guys so thank you and
we'll see you next episode
I
you